[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu connais la dernière norme a dit pas
dans ce jeu c'est pourquoi les martiens
l'ambiance mais leur café donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont toujours des souks où il n'y
a pas trois parlers on est à deux blocs
on arrête tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sinon tu connais la derrière tesco venir
sa famille avec immo retard on va dire
qu'on va chaque golez alors pardon mais
c'est quoi cet accent là je pars je me
sentais comme ça
hu
salut beauté mais je les connais toi
ah bon bernal qui a bloqué les fleurs
nez tu sais que je regarde des 8
je l'ignoré totalement maggie enchanté
mais qui commet maggie les bons tuyaux
d'ailleurs encore tryo jamais un dans ma
culotte
ça m'intéresse pas cernay toi mon chaton
en même temps
[Musique]
québec
vous êtes en état d'arrestation tout ce
que vous savez lire sera retenu contre
nous tout ce que vous pourrez dire sera
dans la phrase c'est vous pouvez garder
le silence mais tout ce que vous direz
pourra être retenu contre eux tu avais
une phrase à après un tacle à dire tout
repose sur mes épaules action tous à
l'état laisser le beau gosse de canal on
va le finir d'encours et lecteurs de
télé 7 jours tellement peña les cascades
de milito tu es un pauvre mytho
[Musique]